hi i'm joe navarro for 25 years i chase
spies for the fbi and today i'm
answering questions on twitter this is
body language support
[Music]
at mcfaul and it comes with a photograph
i'd love to read at cia's analysis of
the body language in in this photo one
of them is in charge one of them is the
subordinate and their body language
clearly is detailing
which is which because when you're in
charge you can sit any style you like
this is your domain when you are the
supplicant when you are there asking for
help your behaviors are more contrite
your arms are more restricted your legs
are restricted and we see all of that
here at the ulterior kid asks are there
secret handshake identifiers
asking for a friend yes
there are many groups out there that
have all sorts of secret handshakes
unfortunately what happens is and you
run into this all the time you go to
shake hands with somebody and they've
interlocked their fingers in a weird way
and all of a sudden you find their index
finger
right here on the inside of your wrist
this is your erogenous zone this is for
intimacy this leaves a very negative uh
feeling or you get these uh social
aardvarks who want to squeeze your hand
to demonstrate that they're strong and
virile and and so forth it just leaves a
a bad feeling in our mouths so are there
handshakes secret handshakes yeah try to
avoid them at nike sandals poppy ass so
a female leg shaking means what
she just cold well
a lot of times we see behaviors that are
repetitive i tend to bounce my legs a
lot some people will twist their ring
some people will crack their knuckles
some people will play with their hair
all repetitive behaviors are
self-soothing behaviors at bait my world
asks how do we identify
bad people bad people are identified by
bad behaviors no one is bad until
we we see demonstrable bad behaviors if
they decide to assault somebody if they
decide to cheat someone if they do
things that are unethical uh immoral or
illegal at courtney reenae asks do men
not know what nonverbal cues and body
language mean or do they just ignore it
i'm a man some people are better at
reading nonverbals than others is there
a difference between men and women and
their ability to read nonverbals the
answer is yes and it's obvious and it's
for biological reasons women bring
babies into the world it is the mother
who spends the most time with a child
and can look at everything from the
texture of the skin to how much humidity
is in the eyes to the color of the lips
that traditionally has been a female
function now that doesn't mean that we
cannot
develop these these skills but from a
pure biological uh
perspective they have that advantage and
that carries through throughout life but
it's one that we men can also
grow
so at p
ritton house that's a very complex
question ordering shawarma today and the
young lady wouldn't look at me in the
eyes that's okay there's no
responsibility to do that i believe she
is syrian
does she
does eye contact means something
important in other cultures eye contact
is both cultural and personal in the
united states for instance in new york
we're allowed to stare at each other for
1.28 seconds in the middle east it's
somewhere around between four and six
seconds that's cultural you may find
yourself in a place where it's personal
and maybe you don't want to make eye
contact i wouldn't put too much emphasis
on eye contact other than
we all have personal preferences lack of
eye contact should not equate to
anything other than this is what the
person chooses from
[Music]
kimitsuka which who asks why do hand
gestures have such an impact humans
evolved to
be very expressive
with their hands a hundred thousand
years ago we were all in the african
savannah we were surrounded by predators
hyenas lions lionesses these large
felines and we had to communicate
silently
but effectively we used our facial
gestures close up and we used our hand
gestures
to
further communicate things such as
direction
anxiety
fear
approach me and so forth this is part of
our paleo circuits we know this because
when we study children who are born
blind then they've never seen
they use the very same hand gestures our
hands attract attention in fact if you
look at your hands no matter how dark
your skin you always notice that the
palms of the hands are very easy to to
read we think that this has given us an
advantage because when we reach out
when we
gesture and so forth even in low light
it sends that powerful but silent signal
the gestures hold our attention
the gestures potentiate the message
at prague
asks what are power poses that i can use
in zoom talks trying to improve my
online presentation skills so we've
talked about power poses in in other
videos and as amy cuddy made famous in
her her ted talks these have to do with
expansive gestures where if you're
sitting down maybe you spread your hands
on the table if you were standing up you
put your hands on your hips with elbows
out even if you're relaxed and sitting
with a group you put your hands behind
your head elbows out these are
territorial displays but
when we are in a virtual environment all
of that goes away because the camera can
only see so much and so what you need to
do is bring them here
have them more in front of the camera
you're using gestures that are formed so
they look like for instance brackets or
the letter c
where you demark and you set boundaries
and it serves not so much as a power
pose
but as a confidence pose and that's what
really matters when you are on a small
screen
at madame ambassador and she asks do you
agree that every
myers-briggs personality type has a
specific body language signature that's
her question and my answer is
no
so great question from at sonia the
freeze and she asks enjoy your power of
body language book thank you
going through it a second time and i'm
wondering what the hell is up with close
talkers our need for spatial distance is
both cultural and personal and so
because each one of us has different
needs what i try to teach is to always
start further apart so let's say you
shake hands maybe you do a fist bump
maybe you shake hands but you do it at a
greater distance and then from that
greater point you self-adjust maybe you
move in closer or maybe you stay where
you're at but we want to honor spatial
differences
simply for this reason anytime somebody
violates our space
no matter how benign it is
we feel uncomfortable it causes what i
call limbic hijacking it makes us hyper
vigilant it makes us uncomfortable
but here's the whammy it also
limits the amount of time that we want
this person to be near us or around us
so
if you want to increase what we call
face time
one of the things that you want to do
is to have an appropriate space
so that everybody
feels
comfortable that can be cultural but it
can also be personal
natalia mvp and she asks are
microexpressions more pronounced when
people are on zoom calls or
are we better at noticing micro
expressions because we keep staring into
the screen so let's start with a couple
of things number one let's try and get
away from micro expressions because in
fact they're just expressions if they
were micro we probably wouldn't see them
if they're fast that they occur very
quickly then we say they are tachy
kinesic as in the tachometer in your car
it moves very fast they yield
information but very quickly so we just
referred to them as gestures so as to
the question when you're on a zoom call
what's going to determine your ability
to observe behaviors actually has a lot
to do with two things the camera that's
being used by the other person and the
lighting if there's grease
or oils or dirt on the on the camera and
it's a low resolution camera little
lighting you're going to miss
these little behaviors to the point that
something that is easy to see live which
is for instance the furrowing of the
glabella this little area of the head if
the camera is not right if the lighting
isn't right you're going to miss these
uh
behaviors one other thing that we've
found that's that's fascinating is that
where you think that maybe having a
neutral face on a virtual call is the
best thing to do it actually works
against you the brain
looks at a face and says this is a happy
person or this is unhappy or possibly a
threat and what happens is when a face
presents is neutral it registers
negatively so what we try to teach
people to do a lot of virtual calls is
to at least not an acknowledgement smile
use your eyebrows to express agreement
or surprise but avoid a neutral face
because when we query those participants
and ask about that person who had a
neutral face they're always rated
negatively
so we have a question from had malik one
and he asked why does shaking your head
mean no and nodding means yes you know
there are behaviors that
over
time become a standardized because of
social conventions we know that for the
most part nodding
the forward nod is perceived as
accepting
as positive as uh
saying yes now there are cultures where
this is not the norm and we see that for
instance
in
bulgaria there are times when when
somebody nods what it means is they
disagree but for the most part
what the research tells us is this as
you go around the world you're pretty
much going to find the same behaviors
these things are universal and that's
why they're so reliable so we have a
question from
anil bodwell and she asks how important
is body posture when delivering speeches
i remember when i was at university and
professors always spoke behind a podium
now
look at ted talks there's no podium
those days are over if you're still
talking behind a podium it's almost
anachronistic in essence a presentation
now has taken on new form because now
when we only have 15 minutes as we see
with corporations that have gone from a
one-hour presentation to 12 or 15
minutes when we go from presentation to
a performance then yeah posture
presence how we look all of that becomes
important
at
aaron chase
asks hey joe
what do you think about teaching
pre-teens and teens body language to
help them stay safe and what are some of
the things you teach them to watch out
for i think we need to teach children at
a very young age about body language in
part because it helps them to navigate a
complex world they go into classrooms
where they may be running into children
that
they've never met before and if we can
teach them some simple things as when
you approach others approach them at
angles not directly because they will
perceive you as friendlier that if you
teach them that if somebody a child is
grabbing their clothing they're probably
shy maybe they're introverted what a
great opportunity to welcome them and be
friendly with them so that they're less
stressed why wait until you're 30 years
old to learn these things why not learn
them at at a very young age and
especially now where
there's so much emphasis on using media
to communicate i would say most
definitely you can begin to teach
children at a very young age what to
look for and they'll thank you for it
in the end
so thank you again thank you for your
questions hope to get some more in the
future you've been watching
body language support